in terms of a person who has a debt and
wants to pay the debt back can they
apply for zakat to pay that debt I fire
the person who's a debtor as mentioned
in the Quran the sixth category is G
those who are in dead so those who are
in debt they can surely ask for zakat
money they can apply they can ask for
zakat money because normally a person
may not be aware that a person is in
debt so he can ask he can even beg and
there's a Hadith in s Muslim number
three Hadith number
3777 where a person comes and begs to
the prophet a lot of loss that is taking
place he buys some fruits and there's a
loss in his business and he's in great
debt so he goes to the prophet and begs
him to help him so the prophet says that
give him out of Charity give him out of
zakat money but even after money was
given it wasn't sufficient to pay his
debt back so the person who owed the Deb
to the prophet says take what you get
and write off the rest of the debt and
there's a Hadith which is mentioned in s
Muslim volume number two in the book of
zakat Hadith number
2271 where a person who in debt he comes
to the prophet and he begs the prophet
for help so the prophet says wait till
we get the satka and inshallah we'll
give the satka money the prophet tells
him that it's not permitted for a person
to beg unless he falls in three
categories number one is unless he's in
debt he can keep on begging till he has
given back his debt category two is a
person who has been struck by a
Calamity and doesn't have the basic
requirements of sustainance so he can
beg till he gets his sustainance and
third is a person who has been Smitten
by poverty and he is very poor and he
comes in the F category then also he can
beg till the time he gets his basic
necessity so for a person who's in debt
According to Islamic Sharia he can apply
he can ask and he can receive the zakat